at room temperature the metal is solid
but it will quickly melt once you put it
in your mouth you'd immediately notice
the sour metallic taste covering your
entire mouth the melted gallium would be
like a thick paste coating your teeth
tongue and everything else with its
silver stain after you struggle to get
it down your throat it would travel into
your stomach at this point you'd be
wondering why nothing has happened to
you yet well that's because in very
small quantities gallium isn't toxic at
all in fact we already have some in our
bodies about 7
mg it doesn't hurt or help our body in
any way and most likely comes from our
water or there might be small traces of
it on our fruits or vegetables